hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to
mind scanners i already got this message
you were saying to
accept any birthday invitations which is
what i plan to do and i always plan to
do
not that i get many but anyway let's see
who needs to be scanned hey
okay we got the data enthusiast we got
this person we got
richard del romeo video game designer
i'm gonna go with
them because
i like the cut of their jib excuse me
can you see we're in the middle of an of
an ember ring here you'll have to wait
until it's over
um well okay you know i'm i don't wanna
i'll be polite
i'll wait after the rituals the embering
concludes with the ritual
words embered and forever remembered
50 minus 50 time okay
well that was inconvenient i'm going to
scan your mind now
uh puzzle man that game is filled with
dead ends nothing is more awful than
dead ends in video games
same goes with the dead ends of society
one should always be able to move on
in any situation always a choice
life is ours to choose after all
[Music]
a regular condo of the boots i like that
all the
that these all require the same
maintenance cost but why must some work
their ass off in order to pay
while i could settle with one hour a
week it's so unbalanced
unfair system yeah a little unbalanced
yeah
the official blue coffee cup rewarding
the people is a classic game design
trick
but coffee i don't even like coffee it
used to be made of organic coffee beans
but nowadays i'm not even sure what it
is
hmm awful phobia the more of a
nah coffee phobia not terror oh no
that's not right wait
wait wait wait wait wait a minute
oh system critic i guess a landscape
painting by azareni
great depth created by clear primary
secondary and tertiary focus points
somewhat the same as short
medium long-term goals used in game
design and politics a gallerist
oh really really really i don't even
know what a gallerist is so i don't know
why i could defend that the gem of the
structure home of politicians scientists
and the constructor
i've been inside many times on visits i
aim to work there within a year's time
as a minister of perhaps even as an
ex-constructor
political career yep
man i am just boned a thousand people
moving in line along core road before
long the structure will be filled to the
brim we need to expand
outward not inward and upwards there's
plenty of room outside these walls
and doubting construction yeah
so there are right and wrong answers in
this a law paragraph
writing new logs is the same as adding
new cards in power hand always make sure
that new rules fit the old rules
laws as game rules i mean technically
true so the most
literal answer is what it is the mind of
del romeo is as laird as his games
but not his balance the praise of his
games is made american
he thinks he can solve anything even
society with his high skills of game
balancing
i mean that's not necessarily insane
i mean it's not crazy i mean yeah of
course he's arrogant
but that's not a crime nor is it insane
i think he's saying i really do honestly
the designer no treatment needed
i don't see why he would need any
treatment i really don't
honestly truly patient declared same
no further action required plus 3k
you got it buddy what a waste of time
and by the way
that method is hugely flawed today it
proved correct but tomorrow it might
describe me as megalomaniac or worse
be careful who you label scanner yeah
yeah yeah i gotcha
you watch your tone i'll label you
whatever i want to label you
we barely have time for anything let's
just end the day we got enough money for
it
do you want to end the day yeah let's go
for it
end of day five maintenance minus seven
i don't know
if it's super super important that i
oh hey buddy today's news there's a rise
in concern among our citizens as outer
zoners continue to gather outside our
city walls
their intention is still unknown i think
their intention is probably very obvious
they either want in or they want to tear
down the walls
the gathering started six days ago and
as today there is an estimated total of
three thousand out zoners camping at the
north gates
and the south gates the constructors
spoke earlier today
i understand your worries but i assure
you we have the situation under control
okay whatever you say who are you stevie
stevie has a mechanical brain implant
the implant is suspected to be illegally
modified by himself and according to his
co-workers
this has caused him to misbehave lately
interesting okay so these two are
relatively nearby
i might be able to knock out two with
one ah there's no way
unless it goes like super well with
oliver here so let me go oliver i don't
think there's a need to do
more than one today so long as i can
stay above my maintenance hello
who are you oh a mind scanner visit i
think your calculations might be off
i am in need of no mind scan but if you
insist i will comply
i might learn something from this sure
yeah let's scan
you i'm on a stage blinded by the lights
son with your looks you'll be his star
that's what he said to me
but i can't just stand there and pretend
to be someone else
acting isn't for me stage fright
no i probably can't lie i can't lie yeah
it's some stupid tv show probably
fantasy oriented
by the looks of it flying dragons and
all that well i'll destroy it with facts
and logic
logical thinking yeah i shouldn't draw
conclusions with my thoughts i'm just
literally interpreting what it is
adam's doing their close dance around
each other they aren't teaching us a
moral lesson just adhering to the law's
emotion
nothing changes when you zoom out obey's
laws of nature
yeah literal interpretation it's the
poster for one of dad's dumb books
look at that vulgar display some
spaceman being abducted by a sentient
intergalactic robot it's just not
plausible dislikes fantasy
yeah pretty much all right
well growing up in a house of fiction
and tall tales led the younger zinski to
demand a solid grip on reality backed by
hard data
this demand has turned him into a square
conformist
i mean yeah but not
insane clearly not he's a little
obsessed with data and logic but isn't
that kind of what this whole system
wants he's saying to me the captain
the captain the captain sure yeah
we'll call him that haitian declared
sane no further action required
plus okay thank you as expected i bet
this looks good in the statistics
well i'll continue my work then have a
nice day
the only thing i regret is declaring
that other guy insane uh 40 yeah i have
time for this
85 might be enough to get through a
insanity check
maybe maybe not oh a mind scanner ah
i did it i finally woke up and began
criticizing our government
and all of a sudden you show up
incredible
well okay let's rid my mind of my
destructive thoughts
well let's see if you have any first my
face on products
the sparkle line the consumers will
never look like me it makes them feel
bad
which makes it easier for the structure
to manipulate this should be stopped
unethical business
[Music]
i mean good point the gates my dad was a
small current engineer there when i was
growing up
he showed me some holes in the wall
where i could peek out on the outer zone
why is it kept from us
questions the rules smiling pretty
deeply there
my old boss mr derek i quit the job
before the sexual harassment charges
that smile needs a good punch i'll tell
you that much knock those teeth right
out
revenge boxer dentist yeah
miss sparkle has developed the
fantastical notion that the structure is
not acting in her best
interest she is clearly against the
system this anti-structure behavior is a
danger to our society
well but is the structure really so bad
is it really so bad you know what hey
steffi sparkle my nickname in high
school used to be
markle sparkle so i'm thinking that
you're 100 sane
you go out there you get them you get
them you go get them steffy patient
declared sane no further action required
i guess you're all right scanner sorry
if i seemed angry before
i just felt that our society is going in
the wrong direction like
we should do something i see you're
doing your part sorry i distrusted you
hey no problem a sparkle's gotta keep
together do i have time to
would it even matter if i talk to this
guy i mean i don't necessarily have to
do the uh
the fixing today right i could end the
day
possibly uh let's see what happens i
don't know if i'm gonna run out of time
if i can come back
i would assume so hi
now this is an insult you do not need to
scan my mind
this brain is 100 compressed knowledge
it will blow your pretty machines to
pieces well let's see about that
let's see about that huh a biodermic
supplex connected to an influential core
interesting concept technique
a plain skin official let the machine do
your job you incompetent sack of flesh
um distrust non-cyborgs
well that's a problem hell yeah techno
blob what an awesome video game
learned a lot from that game when i was
a kid
i'm fascinated with goo oh aren't we all
addicted to video games damn it big
influence oh
you just mean that is a big influence
well god damn it one computer connected
to everything
i seem to be controlling it awesome lust
for power
which is a problem that's beak beak
my mechanical parakeet oh hey there
little guy
loves the machines yeah
okay got you all right clearly you're
insane highly intelligent disrespectful
and lacks empathy towards other people
with lower iq
stevie has an uncontrollable love for
machines which has developed into a
desire for domination using technology
insane in the membrane
koopa technica wow that's a lot of uh
that's a lot of insanity uh okay
well you and your machines are just
piles of junk treat me for what for
being smarter than you
just try me shrinky well um
i think i gotta go uh mostly just
because
i gotta go protects the personality of
your patient for 40 time
well that's good eases stress damn those
are locked anyway i can do anything
about them if i wanted to
de-stress pulp pulse boost personality
reconstructs a personality patient using
an advanced identity radar
well that would be helpful but i can't
do that so i'm just going to end the day
do you want to end the day yes i do i
wonder if i'm like in the middle of
treatment if i could come back and
finish the treatment
i have no idea anyway i did a lot that
day maybe i shouldn't just end the day
early
hi the front man of mike zapata and the
half zips is one of the
most celebrated rock stars in the
structure now his usual message of hope
is giving away to a darker note
well we gotta do a lot of work on this
guy
like a lot a lot of work on that guy i
have two of the things i need to
do for him but i don't know if i have
the time for him he needs a lot of work
like a lot of work and he needs some
personality boosters and i don't even
know if i have time to do that
identity detector restores full
personality okay well let me develop
this one because
it seems valuable search for symbol
press the matching symbol
detects and reconstructs the personality
of the patient using an advanced
identity radar
use the radar to locate a symbol that
matches one of the buttons first thing
you find might not be what you were
looking for
yeah well the personality is gonna be
down there somewhere um
i don't know if i have a lot of time so
let me just go to this guy i definitely
don't have time to finish this guy out
and plus i want to have more
practice and personality before i
attempt to fix a
14 insane person arg what do you want
oh a mind scanner you're here to help me
out keep an eye on things
i don't think we have much time what do
you mean
it'll be any minute now look out for
anything hostile
a fan heavy things falling from the sky
i don't know
anything you're gonna die oh i'm certain
of it
i know with complete certainty that i'll
die at the age of 27.
i don't know how i know or how it's
gonna happen but i'm certain
well this seems bad will i be attacked
by escaped polipeds
maybe i'll stumble into an air vent
instantaneous combustion from a previous
zig dust overdose it's a waiting game at
this point
you have to help me uh yeah okay i don't
have a lot of time
i remember this it's one of the
backstage girls she gave me a palm
reading
she said that she saw great danger up
ahead
believes in prophecies does that
mushroom look poisonous to you
i'm never sure about these things they
might be from one of those off the map
outer zone plantations
pretty sure that thing will kill you
worst case scenario
[Music]
sheet notes i think it's from don't
point that thing at me
might be the song i'm the most proud of
the crescendos especially but
i've lost the touch i can't write
anything worthwhile nowadays
songwriting is worsened
huh zapata is exhibiting extreme
paranoid tendencies believing that his
death will occur in the 27th year
this makes him unable to perform and his
songwriting has never been worse
well he clearly needs help i don't know
if insane is the proper label for him
famophobe
okay so i definitely can't destroy your
personality that's what i gotta attempt
not to do
not sure what to think about that my
friend i mean you're the professional
and all but
what if your machine's what finally
sticks it to me well we'll
uh we'll find out about that we'll find
out about that let me the professional
deal with all that
and you will uh not have to worry about
anything
hey all right uh
um what happens if i don't finish the
treatment all at once
that is a question do i need to finish a
treatment
all in one day in one sitting because
there's no way that i could get through
now but i don't even know if i could get
through 15 in one day
like once you start treatment does it
just like
oh okay i see i see i see okay um
let's go for this you don't like this
well don't worry about it
don't worry yeah there's no way that i
would be able to finish all this
if i was able to do those three in a row
things okay let me
close this end of treatment of ah for
today okay yes we'll come back to this
we're gonna come back to this patient is
resting and i will be back
but also i need to get uh
this thing but i don't have enough time
for that it's only the end of the day
yeah let me end the day and i need to be
able to restore his personality
100 because i don't want to lose that
because otherwise he'll never be able to
do anything
performative again you see your daughter
trapped in a sea of wires
well that's not good we'll get my
daughter out of the wires
oh hi incoming facts id number 34424
do not share do not discuss do not
question
okay the pulse is on the rise this
vicious illness develops in the carrier
as a compounded force similar to an
electric current
this disruptive force can be released on
purpose or accidentally due to an
instability
either way the results are catastrophic
and should be stopped at all costs
uh what's the pulse the faraday program
is our newest effort at the zhingnoka
institute it is created to eliminate the
pulse
we are currently examining five carriers
of the pulse
known as disruptors if you encounter any
disruptors or any signs of
the pulse report to us immediately
i don't know what the pulse is the
faraday program is our best defense
against the pulse earn a level 3
citizenship and you too can
join the faraday program for normality
and the mind
love love love lots of love lovingly
love love
the structure finally found a way to
eliminate the pulse those disruptors
must be stopped before they destroy
all zignoka-based machines
yes i am worried i am running on zignoka
myself you know
heck the whole city is well back to work
scanner
who are you by the way who are you
anyway i gotta
i'm gonna finish out this treatment
you're not carrying any sharp objects
are you
no not particularly um i needed to get
this thing right
removes up to three of these in a row
mirrors to sold the patient through the
eyes
the organic machine mirrors the soil the
patient through the eyes match the
pattern to extract the insanity from the
soul
use the three eye buttons to match the
sequence of symbols within the patient's
eye
recreate the sequence confirm the
sequence well let's treat you
okay these are back again be careful
with that thing you got it
okay sorry what was that
c u x
nice okay uxc
ux i know these aren't the right words
but
okay i do not have that thing i wish i
had it
uh but let's restore some personality
here
all right what am i doing oh
yeah oh there we go
oh oh there we go getting some
personality back
there we go don't worry buddy i got you
there we go no problem
[Music]
sorry pal i know that probably wasn't
too
pleasant let's get some let's get some
of this going
uxx blamo
got why these got to be all jumbled up
like this
ah sorry sorry sorry oh sorry sorry i do
oh my god oh man that's a hard target to
hit
not my favorite thing
all right is this the right one for this
wait am i correct on this
cxu
[Music]
okay oh man this is tough
all right
no god damn it okay no no no no we're
fine we're fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine
okay time's up your work day has ended
the citizen requires further treatment
yes
they do yes they do i am running out of
money maintenance minus seven
my goodness i am running out of money
hi today's new this is tough this is
tough today's nude this morning a
strange
and unregistered man was seen doing
strange things near a big vent look out
for this strange man and be careful he
is very very strange
[Music]
okay well let's finish out this because
i need the money
hopefully i can get that stress down how
do you get the stress down
de-stress pulse okay so this is clearly
not working so let me get the
de-stress pulse developed hit the target
in the middle
a pulse aimed straight at the heart i
don't know what
zing noka is it's ignoca but it can't be
too healthy if you're blasting it right
in the heart
and eventually i would just get all the
tools necessary to be able to do this
but i don't exactly have
money to do that so let me uh treat you
for stress
first let's hit you right in the heart
oh wow what is that thing oh you're
gonna love it
you're gonna de-stress oh yeah how you
like that
pretty good right let's get your your
personality back reconstructed because i
really
really blasted it away you know well
there we go
okay we're looking at this bad boy
okay now we're gonna blast you out well
actually let's do this one because it's
safer
let's see xcu you got
x c u x u
bam gone and then watch this we're gonna
finish this off
[Music]
you're gonna be a-okay
nice that's how you do you are treated
and your personality is intact
treatment complete plus 15k that'll get
me through the day
oh man i guess i must have made it up or
something
i guess no one can see into the future
anyways
i need to get to my studio stat i have
this banging tune in my head
laters and thanks a lot i actually help
them
i actually help them i actually honestly
helped somebody
i didn't think it was possible i didn't
think that i could do that
but i actually helped somebody that's
pretty good and i have all the tools
necessary to help this person
with their insanity hey shrinky let's
test your intelligence
what is the name of the chip that powers
the cx-88 inside data goggles
i'm ignoring you the smile on stevie's
face washes away he seems annoyed
that's great oh he's stressed well i can
fix that
but first let's fix your other problems
okay perfect let's get this
i don't know what this one is
there you go buddy there you go pal okay
what do we got
xc what was that last one damn it
xcc
[Music]
that's probably going to be it for today
time's up workday's ended
yeah i'll get back to you don't worry
buddy don't worry buddy i'm gonna fix
you up good
now that i know that time can just end
zapata's agents
just sent you two tickets to their
concert at the saucer two months from
now
she said that he is relieved filled with
energy and eternally grateful for your
help
you know that feels better than actually
destroying people's lives
i'll go with you if you don't have a
date
hey big talking mouth there uh
you know maybe hey maybe mind scanner
you have accumulated 86
science at this juncture it is my
privilege to congratulate you on your
level 2 citizenship
great being a level two citizen comes
with many perks
free parking access to better vegetables
and don't forget
become a level three citizen and you get
access to the zanoka institute
okay return to patient well thankfully
it doesn't take any extra time hey
drankie what does a mind scanner and an
idiot have in common
everything
okay whatever what do we got what we got
this
oh what is this so this monstrosity is
going to oh my god
okay there's one
there's one of those
[Music]
blasted away okay what do you got
xuu
[Music]
easy peasy
three
[Music]
easy you're making it easy on me
super easy oh the personality oh no no
no no no the personality
[Music]
hey what you looking at would you look
at that
would you look at that would you look at
that oh yeah you'll go on a date with me
hey why do i sound like krillin from
dragon ball z abridged okay um
yeah back to this now what do we got
four easy easy easy blammo
[Music]
all right i could do one more and then i
do personality boost
what is that lipto
sign sign lipto sign sign
okay and then i'm gonna boost your
terminality oh there we go that's a
strong signal
there we go there you go yeah we're
going to restore this bad boy
you are so restored you are welcome pal
you're welcome
you liptolipto
[Music]
god you have so much of this crap whoa
what the hell
uh eight
[Music]
bam okay obliterated those let's get the
personality back
up there we go uh
let's see this one i don't know if these
are faster
but they seem a little safer use sine
sine
u sine sine
[Music]
okay
what what what six oh god damn it okay
let's
it's fine five that's five
oh okay we can do this last one it's
totally fine
i don't need to restore
god done you're fine
treatment complete patient is fantastic
there you go okay i admit it
the sprain implant was kind of going
haywire i guess i think i can thank you
for setting my head straight
i think i'll settle for this level of
intelligence and put it to better use
see you around i did it i did it
even in retirement often is considered
to be the most accomplished athlete of
the structure
always the picture of physical and
mental health offman has now begun to
show erratic
behavior well off man you're gonna be on
man when i'm done with you
don't you worry about a thing i'm a
professional
ah please i need more time i i
wait i'm sorry i mistook you for someone
else
the name is often call me paris please
i trust you here to give me help me get
rid of my creditor
uh maybe you're in horrible debt i'm
guessing that's the man himself
old nick some people see his horns
others do not
i never saw them personally but i would
recognize that smile anywhere
memory for faces damn it was probably
obsessed by devil god damn it
oh i never know which one it actually is
the podium the view is best from the top
but i see a familiar face in the crowd
and it scares me followed
a clock its hands are spinning out of
control the time has come
stressed or awaiting death not stressed
stressed
damn it is probably waiting god damn it
his forked tongue it's moving
as he tempts me to agree we just shook
hands on it at first the contract came
later
feels tricked
the javelin was always my favorite
discipline this looks like a metal
tipped one
hasn't been in use since a union
switched to hollow tips it'll hurt all
right
expects punishments
yeah our contract
written in blood the paper does not tear
feels trapped so it's whatever the flaw
is i guess
i guess yeah severe insecurity has led
often to believe that his achievements
were bestowed by the devil
he now seems to think that the devil has
returned to claim his due
[Music]
yeah you need some hell buddy you need
some help
the diabilitation odd diablo irritation
the reflector awaiting treatment
well yes it would be a mistake not to
take this seriously
scanner my dad is collecting interest as
we speak
okay um all right um okay uh well i've
got the candelabra i don't have the
other things i don't have time really to
make the other things but i do have
this one yeah so really i just need the
generic and then these two
i could probably get started with some
treatment on you because if i don't have
the
cross i can always just default to the
generic one so let's let's get some
treatment in anyway
oh and of course it's a cross okay so
we're going for a cross
mmm cross no way that thing looks
dangerous oh trust me
it is absolutely 100 100 dangerous
incredibly dangerous actually there you
go
i definitely don't have time for
anything else so let's just go ahead and
wait it out
all right i'll be back don't worry i'll
be back and i'll fix you right up buddy
further treatment
you know it you know it pal i bet you
could go through this whole thing
without any of the extraneous things but
the ability to do the combos is really
what makes a difference you received a
package from stevie
it's probably good i'll open it the
package contains multiple small devices
and a note saying
i do not need these things anymore maybe
you can find use of them
thanks again doctor ah sell them i need
the money
sell them five five wow
ah five is good today's news another
incident of the pulse occurred at jack's
noodle diner in the boots an oven
exploded as one of the chefs was
preparing a meal
luckily no one was hurt the owner jack
francis comments
if i'd known he was a jammer i would
never have hired him
the disruptor has been arrested i guess
he was a jammer why you gotta be so far
away wake up wait give me some way why
are you going to why you go over there
right i can fix it i can fix them in
this time i swear i can't i'm gonna keep
an eye on that personality you look like
someone with a competitive spirit am i
right
i play to win i play the win of course
you do
of course but remember to factor in the
cost take it from someone who knows
you got it pal all right let's get you
treated you know if it's just singles
i'm just gonna do this
yeah if it's just singles like there's
no real point in doing the other ones
because they take longer
if i can hit these properly which i can
give me some in a row come on okay
personality is dropping let's get this
there we go uh
let's go ahead and do this one
i guess that was pretty easy uh these
are better
you know these are better these are just
plain old better
oh the jiggles wiggly
wiggly
all right let me get this going again
build this back up
that's not it there we go whoa there we
go
uh
okay we gotta do these oh god that's a
that's tough
hey hit it i hit it though here we go
come on
yes yes
well that only did one personality blast
okay we're not gonna have a lot of time
but he's he's doing pretty good so far
my patient is doing very well even
though this is
pretty tough
i got one in i got one in work day has
ended citizen requires further treatment
yeah they do i know they do i'm working
on it
end of day 11 maintenance negative seven
okay we're okay
we are surviving hey this is monica
i'm calling about the birthday party
will you join us
yeah i'll be there great the party goes
down at red lake docks
see you red lake docks
red lake red lake dogs
can i finish my treatment of this dude
can i
can i finish my treatment of this dude i
i will i promise i'll have time
you know you don't have to be shy about
if you want to autograph oh
yes please here you go i keep them close
by just in case
thank you means a lot
okay let's get those jiggles going
what's that max there we go
bam okay and then the last one
okay this one
nice bam done easy
nailed it your treatment is complete
buddy
plus 15k well done pal
i feel less tense no doubt about it at
the same time i feel that i've lost an
old friend
or perhaps an old fiend i owe you my
thanks
mindscape there's a signed trading card
of me holding a trophy
see you thank you thank you
that's really good i'm gonna go to the
docks apparently
for a birthday party hi
nice to finally meet you we'll leave the
names out for now
your radio phone could be listening do
you mind handing it over
all right here i don't need to ask why i
see why she carefully replaces a pin
from the back of your radio phone and
hands it back
there our signal will not be scrambled
the structure will have a hard time
intercepting our communication we will
continue to meet in physical form
right here by the lake my dad used to
take me fishing here all the time
lord knows what mutated horus swim in
that filth nowadays anyway
have you heard about the outer zoners
there's a growing concern in the
structure as their numbers grow outside
the gates we believe this is our chance
we believe these outer zoners can help
us overthrow the constructor
that's why we're currently trying to
establish contact with them just think
about it
the gates open all the fresh air of the
world
if it is fresh air out there i heard you
received level 2 citizenship
as a mind scanner this means you've
received some information
sure i don't even have a choice here
doesn't say much except the faraday
program
the structure is developing a weapon
against disruptors this means a lot to
us
skin your credit to your kind now i
suggest we walk in separate directions
i don't even know if i should be helping
you nice girl
i do like rebels oh hi
what i have feelings too you know
moonrise
oh that no she scrambled me i won't tell
the structure even if i wanted to
just do your thing i won't stand in your
way scanner
what are you by the way okay thank you
that's weird i don't understand that
fully beset by overwhelming sadness
kumara has quit her job and is rapidly
running out of kapok
her inability to paint her maintenance
is surely adding to her grief
well that's sad um
i guess i'll scan you woe is me
woe is oh hey you here to cheer me up
forget about it i'm what they call
inconsolable
want me to spell that for you what's
wrong what isn't wrong
i feel empty don't see any reason to
continue
while i go back to work why even go
outside i'm you know
down well let me scan you and see what's
up
a bottomless pit the walls are smooth
unnatural
like in the zagnoca mines except this
one goes straight down
i don't see any light in a dark place
looks like my old camera back when i
still worked in photojournalism
wasn't the same after they moved me to
the copy department taking pictures was
everything to me
downgraded a list of my unanswered calls
man that's a long list don't know if
i'll ever get around to reply to all of
them
seems so overwhelming
no energy kumara seems to be suffering
from a general lack of purpose and drive
her dark and depressive mindset makes
her an unfit for any jobs and the
maintenance clock is ticking
well she clearly needs help i don't like
to label people as
insane but tristalia the design
awaiting treatment you think this
darkness has something to do with my
mind
well i won't disagree but to be honest
i'm not sure what we can do about it
i don't hold much hope that's all okay
so the candelabra the bootly dooley
and then oh i have all the things that i
need to treat you oh this will make it
easier
what's up first this one one two three
four five six seven
oh they're eight it's all
[Music]
okay good just getting started i don't
know how far we'll get let's get those
jiggly bits going
this one's the toughest one because it's
all kind of hard to tell sometimes
there we go the jiggly bits
okay
[Music]
i don't know if i'm going to get any
jiggly so let's try to get a personality
going
and the time we have left i'm a hero i'm
a hero i'm a hero i'm a hero what is
that what is that what is it it's this
i almost missed clicked time's up
maintenance thank you at least i'm doing
okay on money
and i don't know what's going on with
moonrise oh your daughter smiles at you
she looks different from how you
remember
well that's not good we need to know
more about this faraday programmy
your daughter must be one of the test
subjects this has led us to believe that
your daughter has the power of the pulse
the pulse is a disruptive force that can
shut down any zignoca-based machine
basically anything that runs in the
structure
your daughter might be the very key to
our salvation we'll be in touch
no hugs no kisses moonrise
so you just want to use my daughter too
who are you zx81 appeared out to know
her a few days ago he claims to be a
robot but even the most untrained eye
will see through this act
well i don't have time for you because
i'm at the end of this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching
hope you're enjoying this so far it is
very interesting and fun and i do like
it
it's just a fascinating exploration into
people's minds and like them
the definitions of what is helping and
not helping and like trying to walk this
line it's it's crazy to think of but
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and uh
have you listened to dystractable if you
haven't it's clearly a flaw in your mind
and i need to scan it
to see what the uh insanity is causing
you not to look indestructible
link's in the description anyway thanks
again and as always
i will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you